so then to verify that the information  is correct i would  check with my informant bundles my  problem is i have all my bundles on my  reader for the years 2015 2016 2017 and  2018.  in the meantime vegas carlson  has successfully defended against the  youngsters of duda  hard-fought game comes to an end  absolutely  yeah and uh yeah they it's it was a very  interesting game actually  so they they have a lot to discuss but  they also have a an important date  tomorrow so  probably the post martin one go won't go  for too long  yeah magnus saying i'm not gonna play  this crap again  suffering the whole game  [Music]  and judah is saying yep big boy  i almost had shot  you come at the king you better not miss  the knights who say ne  yep oh  there's a drawing of lots carson is  saying give me  the black pawn